can anyone tell me in what way the
border is open and I really want to know
I'm I'm I looked and I said okay let's
look at all changes at the border from
Trump to Biden and I can't find any way
in which that border is open the Biden
Administration has repeatedly said the
border is closed just like Trump did
they have said people should not attempt
to cross illegally just like Trump did
the administration sent troops to the
Border increased surveillance increased
technology at the border worked with
Mexico to deter migration to the United
States and importantly since title 42
expired the number of people encountered
trying to cross has decreased despite
the fear-mongering by Republicans